hello I'm good how are you hello you two
this is Mary Jean this is Mary how are
you I'm the last professional
broadcaster Sara good see ma'am that's
Jim Nora welcome what's that did you
finally did I finally yes Dale Laila
[Laughter]
are you a big boxing fan yeah have you
professional fights of the event - I've
only been to one I'm not as big a boxing
either you have what was the most
amazing when you've been to maybe George
Foreman when he was at his his career at
that point oh yeah who was he fighting
do you remember a bomb a bomb was it
like Alex Stewart find out if I might
and a bomb did he win yes there is
something weird about a championship
fight when they're walking in like when
you're watching two guys about to fight
the energy in that room of watching him
walk out there really is nothing like
that
I'll tell you what the other fact that I
saw that was an insane fight was a Mike
Tyson against Frank Bruno and Frank was
a friend of mine and his father Frank's
father was his trainer right so I was in
the room with Frank and he was warming
up and you're Frank's like this Adonis
he's like six foot seven is he British
or no British yeah yeah and he lasted
five when you watching a guy like Frank
Bruno about to go out and fight Mike
Tyson Tyson at that time was a
devastating I know he might been
undefeated at that point he changed the
room listen before he walked into the
ring the room changed at the MGM Grand
in Vegas when he just walked in
everybody went oh when Tyson walked in
oh yeah yeah I hate seeing my friend
fight Mike Tyson that's what I wonder is
not the position I want my friend to be
in you know and you can imagine because
you know Mike was sure sure and Frank
six seven he just went to the body like
some
nobody's business when you when you when
you when Frank Bruno's get ready to
fight Mike Tyson you're in the are you
trying to pump them up in the dressing
room I showed you got this or you like
just saying nothing I've just kind of
gone good luck you suspect that your
friends about to go out there and good
luck there and you know the guy was you
know Mike was on a roll at that point
you know let's face it it was just going
crazy did you ever want to fight i box
but no that's not what you wanted to do
for a lot anymore yeah not me no I
always wondered that because they you
know a lot of times as rock stars or
actors people who are very successful at
this one thing when once they get there
it's like okay I achieved my dream
that's now what's net like like they
want to go be a boxer they works out the
second thing never works out right no
more casted oh no he tried to box bar
cast-off majeski [ __ ] beaten out of them
that's exactly what is yeah but guys
like him Joe Klecko like they're big
dudes but it doesn't matter you let go
come on now what do you ever try to you
just train boxing because you like to
exercise because it's just training and
you know it's fun to beat the [ __ ] out
of things right well how long did you
train for well I still do oh you still
do okay so you can actually handle
yourself now it's very therapeutic
I was watching Richie I'm like I'm gonna
do that and it actually it's a great
workout screwed up these reputation just
[ __ ] artists out of the royalties and
so many problems I mean you with Bon
Jovi for so many years but was there
ever a point where you like god I'm this
executive is screwing us did you ever
feel like you guys were getting screwed
over by anybody no because I became the
president of the record company yes you
did so you kind of had a grasp on the
business end of it really early yeah
people taught me they did have you made
enough money now though we're like you
don't even worry about that anymore like
if you're getting [ __ ] it's like yeah
but I got all those money which I mean
now you don't just out of principle you
don't want to
right we get that in there but you know
hey we had a really good run and when
you left my having a good run when you
left Bon Jovi was it like that movie
rockstar that's how I envisioned it
because I was reading an article and it
said that you just like one day you just
didn't show up and you're just like I'm
done I'm done for my legs would not
carry me out the dope right but in that
movie Rockstar Mark Wahlberg did the
same thing he was on stage and one day
he just left and he's just out of the
band
and I love that movie so I'm like is
that is that is that how you did it no
no we're not gonna talk about that
because there's an amalgamation of
things that happens you know being in a
band not the easiest thing in the world
because you know you're married to five
guys right right and everybody
experiences fame and fortune at
different speeds right and you know hey
I I was in that band for 31 years and we
did some damage you know so it was
pretty good and yeah like you said when
there's five people in any situation
there's gonna be jealousy differences of
opinions reacting to fame yeah yeah
reacting to fame it's gotta be hard
jealousy no jealousy it's not for me
anyway no no but I mean you know if I
always say to me hey you wanna be you
know like should shouldn't the band be
named like [ __ ] or something like then
I went definitely now you never wanted
that man that's not that's not what it
was I give good band
you were also but yeah you were a huge
famous part of that band you weren't
some unknown guitar I'm it's like you
know everyone knows Mick but they it's
Keith Richards they you were one of
those guitars that everybody knew as
well well thank you for that but I don't
really think so but you don't think so
no not really not yet I'm actually
excited because what happens is now or
and I have a chance to reinvent
something well how did you meet in Maui
through Alice Cooper and I was on tour
with Alice for like 300 years and Richie
came because he was vacationing so we're
doing this charity show for New Year's
Eve and connection you know instant
chemistry we got off the stage started
jamming out and um yeah I just
felt like it was just there you know the
energy between us and she's playing his
ass off
well the Alice get annoyed that you're
now leaving your tour to go with him
that was like nearly four years ago
he did oh yeah and you know I I gave him
you know a few months notice and
everything it wasn't like a week or
anything okay that would still if you
couldn't find anybody for the first
couple of weeks I'd be there but they
found Nita Strauss who's awesome and
she's doing a great job
so everything's good now and I had a
bunch of songs together we had a couple
hits together I produced some stuff for
her you know so we were friends and as
an artist he respected that or he needed
to be an artist not just somebody that
was in his band yeah yeah not like it
was like a you know it wasn't a big
thing but Shep was kind of annoyed Shep
was because it's like hey here's another
phone call I gotta make to do something
different right complicating my dear
court Richie thanks a bunch
right well this is so supportive we're
doing loves Ritchie and he actually sang
on one of our songs so okay so he
doesn't hate you first yeah an artist
that understands that another artist has
to do something that's gonna make a
difference you know there's no there's
no dismay or does no decidua Shep ever
make up now you know now we look back
with my brother Doc McGhee you know you
know we decided to put the old team back
together and okay see what happens there
he manages kiss yes okay he still
doesn't manage kiss yes is there another
band that so how'd the membership
changes right right you know membership
membership and you don't say the bank's
membership card yes they have you bought
the coffin yet you should I have not but
a lot of people that I do soon
that's what I want to be Barry I know I
might want to do that hot you know you
wouldn't go with a kiss coffee why not
it's good to get some of this has got
some personality go Robert Johnson
coughing that's all right it's really
classy move the kiss Oh in a tuxedo
right do you so you guys have a holiday
snot coming out do you worry that like I
feel like the the Christmas song market
is getting very competitive just last
night I don't know if you guys heard DMX
hey that guy sings for a guy who lisps
he really is dynamite you're stepping on
Michael bublé's toes but then DMX put
out Rudolph the red-nose right red-nosed
reindeer last night did you hear that
yeah Rudolph the red-nosed reindeer I
just I don't know if you can compete
with DMX you don't worry about that this
song you know I actually do song it's
not really a holiday song but it is
right it's called one night of peace
all right buddy of mine piece of ass was
you know about to go into Iraq yet
Saddam you know and he was a good friend
of mine and he couldn't tell me where he
was at that point and he said you know
listen I don't know if I'm gonna get out
of here
so would you do me a favor and just take
care of my kids get two kids and a wife
and um I said of course man and the song
was built out of that emotion you know
and luckily my book came back and we had
a great song but it's 25 years old and
usually you know you don't kind of do
that it basically comes from the present
moment and what's happening but this is
something that was very timeless and it
could be a Christmas song or it could be
just a great song
it works year-round right yeah there's a
lot of pressure to put on you though
like you know as a friend like you know
I'm gonna ask my friend to watch my kid
telly but do you have to kind of say yes
if someone else well not not I mean look
we're really close just even taking care
of his affairs
you know where the other things I did
for the troops was actually put together
by Doc we went to Camp Pendleton and you
know when these kids come home in a box
they kicked their families off the the
base yeah but a month Wow because they
got new people coming in so we did a big
show and Beyonce was on it too that's
fine I really you know in our time
society infidelity yeah can you believe
that a rock star committing infidelity
not me that's crazy I'm the only way I
cheated on Oreos with my guitars because
they kind of look like women that's the
only thing I get away with really yeah
do you how do you it must be difficult
being in a relationship and being a rock
star especially like a rock star from
your era Bon Jovi was known for like as
they say grab on Jovie that's rough on
Jovi what does that mean are you kidding
no a German panic came out they were
actually better than us it was con Jovi
yeah but you guys got fantastic I mean
amazing I swear to god this German band
was like I went to see him one night and
I said that was like really do enjoy
called conch oe
boo Bon Jovi had a good run of getting
quite a bit of puss right so to speak
well he's married but that's what I mean
like like no I meant for talking about
the band you know what I mean like as a
whole women love that band as a whole
right no it's not you know yeah
basically you grow up yeah but in the
eighties it's like different when you're
younger it's like you know yeah who
cares yeah right you got no money right
you know and it was a different time
there's no cell phones there's no
everybody cap no TMZ nothing yeah
nothing yeah I was
look it was a lot of fun right
does she know she don't go yeah are you
shipping around there way long you
probably got a date someone who you've
been in bands for so you're not shocked
by rock star behave because you've been
in a band
his reputation didn't intimidate you no
good let me ask you that because because
I will tell you why yeah believe it or
not I was always a gentleman I was not
that kind of you know I was a serial
dater I guess are you like you
monogamist absolutely okay Wow when
you're in a band too when you're like
you worked with Alice Cooper whoever it
is do the guys who you work with in the
band tend to fall in love with you
because you're it's a very intimate
relationship you're touring together
you're spending time in the bed in the
bus not even sex but it's all for you
but today exactly right yeah right yeah
right but in my dreams guys you yeah yes
Sam no because it's so cool everyone I
get to me on this show so I'm just like
wow right cool right my clothes for you
I'm like would that be Orion so let's
say like somebody was like Oh Richie I
just want to take my clothes off for you
would you be like don't do that or let
you be exact like what smarty fantastic
right okay you can't mess around with
girl with a hat no you look
had to a lot I don't look particularly
good in hats as hard as that is to
believe you don't like it without them
that's a great point yeah what right I
don't know I've been called a homely
mopey [ __ ] but that's what you say yeah
you're right penis that's exactly the
stop my
[Laughter]